ich werde ihre
außen
knusprig hast du
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute wenn ich nicht
alleine in der küche denn ich backe
zusammen mit innenfutter blog ist
schönes sogar bis juli danke dass ich
mal in einer fremden küche zu gast sein
und gebacken heute die cookies das sind
richtig dicke große xxl cookies aus new
york ich würde sagen ich zeige dass
erstmal so die zutaten bleiben und so
ein bisschen ein und dann fangen wir an
zu packen allerdings benötigen weißen
zucker dann habe ich hier noch braunen
zucker ein bisschen kartoffelstärke
backpulver an schokolade brauchen mit
zart bitter und vollmilch walnüsse ein
bisschen wald kalte butter und noch mehr
ich würde sagen so einfach direkt
loslegen das sind gute zutaten und
beiden katzen denke ich sofort in der
mitte sind die wahrscheinlich so
wahnsinnig weil ich aus und schluss
bleiben ich habe noch nie was von diesen
grün keksen gehört aber ich bin gespannt
ich weiß mich gerne überraschen ist auch
tatsächlich so läuft ihr das noch nicht
vorher in deutschland gesehen haben wir
wollen hier sind die allererste sind die
allerersten die die hier probieren ja
genau wir machen dass er nicht nur damit
wie gleich richtig fette guck ich zum
essen haben sondern möchten euch nicht
nur die leckeren kekse näherbringen
sondern auch die kekse dies im internet
gibt also diese cookies die immer so
aufklappen wenn man jetzt eine internet
seite öffnet da kann man welche annehmen
oder man kann sie aber
was soll das überhaupt und was machen
die da das wollen wir euch ein bisschen
näher bringen und deshalb haben wir uns
zusammengetan mit abbas das ist ein
weltweit führendes unternehmen für
digitale sicherheit und privatsphäre
weil es ist nämlich gar nicht so klar
welche cookies man annehmen sollen nicht
aber du kennst dich da auch gut aus das
stimmt ja also mit cookies kenne ich
mich aus weil ich einerseits super gerne
cookies es aber auch ich bin ja in der
online-welt zu hause genauso wie du mehr
oder weniger aber guck ich hab keinen
shop es ist gar nicht so schwer zu
verstehen kugel führt stücke die die
webseite quasi über den web browser
speichert damit die ganzen funktionen
halt klappen und funktionieren der
warenkorb gespeichert wird
aber ich würde sagen wir starten direkt
mal bei den gummi cookies aus new york
ist es so dass die wirklich in einer
variante walnüsse und
schokolade nehmen und dann wirklich die
vielleicht bitten eni kannst du darüber
kein hatten ja schokolade hatten es ist
immer schwierig weiß somit darf er nicht
naschen wenn nachher fehlen ihr ein paar
jahre das ist wenn ich alles abgewogen
ist das ist ja beim backen anders also
im kochen dann musste alles aufs
gretchen genau wie soja du nicht nee ich
mag es immer nach gefühl für mich aber
auch cool ich jetzt auch einmal die
kalte butter in die schüssel
habe die richtig flüssig geschlagen die
wird richtig profi aufgeschlagen mit dem
zucker sorten butter und zucker zusammen
passt sowieso immer immer immer und wenn
du das dann richtig schön lange schlägt
dann wird die butter immer so schön
fluffig
ich schreibe euch alle ganz eng angaben
wie immer unten in die infobox es ist
fast schon so einen kick inits format
ich habe ja clique miet und das ist ein
kiebitz eben nur dass wir halt heute
auch noch mal über angeguckt quatschen
genau ich habe immer das problem wenn
ich auf seiten gehe ich hab's ja dann
sehr eilig weil ich ja irgendwas kaufen
will soll man dann wirklich alle cookies
wenn er steht cookies ablehnen oder dann
manchmal steht auch konfigurieren was
ist eigentlich besser versorgen machen
ich gebe zu ich mache es relativ häufig
des tages akzeptieren ja weil es so
schnell geht und du denn habe
wahrscheinlich stellschrauben möchte so
geht es mir eigentlich auch auf es dann
also wenn du die cookies annimmst ist
kann es ist nicht immer verkehrt aber es
gibt zum beispiel auch cookie diebstahl
da muss man aufpassen das heißt wenn man
alles einfach wahllos annimmt kann es
sein dass cyberkriminelle zum beispiel
sich da irgendwie an die daten machen
und dann lag finden ihren irgend ein
schlupfloch finden seine daten waren ein
bisschen
ja das hört sich schon super kriminellen
aber ist es ja auch im endeffekt daher
sollte man sich da schon ja so ein
bisschen darüber informieren
lok schokolade hatten es nicht einfach
das ist auch nicht meine liebste
aufgabenfelder wie sie deswegen hier
gegeben sehr gemein ich werde mich
rächen
so ich fahre jetzt an schon mal
zuschlagen und müssen wir haben 22
minuten damit richtig schön dick wird
und danach kommen die eier nacheinander
setzten
es ist immer so schön ich mag nicht so
oft mit anderen praktisch übertrieben
back begeisterten menschen ich habe ja
meine gäste sind meistens sollte die
nicht so gern war die nur essen januar
11 uhr musik
also die eier habe ich jetzt
nacheinander eingerührt das ist ganz
wichtig dass ich gezeigt einfach
verbindet und eine homogene masse wird
und dann kann ich parallel schon mal die
trockenen zutaten miteinander verrühren
ich glaube das werden sehr gute küche
im gegensatz zum internet da gibt es ja
auch sehr viel schlechte cookies es gab
eine umfrage von erwartet dass knapp die
hälfte der deutschen gar nicht weiß was
die cookies sind im internet was die
eigentlich machen und dann gibt es wohl
schlechte die wirklich nicht gut sind ja
weiß welche das sind und was die machen
es kommt immer ganz drauf an also
möchtest du das volle web seiten
erlebnis dann ist es macht schon sinn
cookies zu akzeptieren wenn auch viele
sagen dass man dann gar nicht alles
sehen kann auf der seite ja das
tatsächlich so einige plugins eventuell
eingeschrieben hat
jetzt durch mein online schafft und so
habe ich mir solche wörter angeeignet
habe auch mal ich habe tatsächlich mal
wirtschaftsinformatik studiert aber
irgendwann wenn du merkst du okay ich
wechsele aber es ist auch so dass jetzt
diese durch diese neuen
datenschutzgesetze sind ja auch
webseiten betreiber verpflichtet dazu
diese diese aufforderung ob du das dann
nimmst oder updates zu zu fragen zu
stellen und daher bleibt es immer auf
einigen ja auch schon genervt da vorne
weiß macht schon sinn vor allem wenn du
zum beispiel auch werbung die auf mich
zugeschnitten sind so dass er mal so
schöne kleider an und wenn du jetzt zum
beispiel nach weiteren teil dann suchst
dann bekommst du zum beispiel wenn du
auf anderen seiten gab es ja auch
werbung angezeigt dies ja auch nicht
zugeschnitten das heißt du bekommst
keine werbung von baumaschinen oder
sowas und an von kleidern also ist es
kann ja auch sinn machen oder wie sieht
das eigentlich so praktisch ja oder also
es ist denn auch cookies die man eher
nicht akzeptieren sollte hast du hast du
da schon erfahrung gemacht böse wenn ich
jetzt überlege ich persönlich noch nicht
aber durch den datenklau et cetera also
man sollte da schon ein bisschen
vorsicht weil ich immer alles durch
liegen und konfigurieren auf jeden fall
das macht schon sinn ich habe mir da mal
ein paar zahlen aufgeschrieben die fand
ich total faszinierend und zwar bei
einer umfrage von erfasst haben sie
herausgefunden dass 44 prozent der
befragten regelmäßig alle cookies
einfach akzeptieren ok und dann wurden
sie natürlich gefragt warum macht ihr
das und das waren auch richtig viele 60
prozent haben dann gesagt ich möchte so
schnell wie möglich an die webseite
rannten und ich find das dann auch immer
noch relativ groß dass es 16 prozent
nicht wissen wie überhaupt leben können
das finde ich schon dass hier der uns
schon hohe teilen tatsächlich zählte
auch mal zu dem 44 prozent
dass ich mich so ein bisschen damit
befasst habe wenn du alles wahllos
akzeptiert und einfach sagt ja ja und
amen dann kann es sein dass der
webseiten-betreiber deine daten auch an
drittanbieter abgeben kann also das
möchte man ja nicht mehr da fühlt man
sich ja auch so ein bisschen unsicher
dann um es genug ist ja so ein bisschen
ausgenutzt genau und daher nur die
funktionalen cookies akzeptieren die
paar sekunden zeit sollte man sich schon
nehmen ok und wenn ja wen ist unser gab
es ja auch weiter kommen ja alles so
genau man das alles war ein verein also
ich würde ich erst mal nur die trockenen
zutaten habe ich ja vorab schön verrührt
und verbindet sich einfach mit dem
motto tage nicht bewusst aber nur so den
zuschauern zu erklären und dann alles
rein gar nicht erst sieben das
verrichtet nur ein paar sekunden
da kann ich ja auch nach dem tipp geben
dass sie haben war es meistens unnötig
weil es hat man früher wie ungeziefer
mir das hätte ich nicht auch sehr
faszinierend ja aber ich muss sagen bei
mir ist es noch drin dass ich trotzdem
liebe das ist ja alles schön so genau
weil man das so von oma kennt und von
mama wenn du mama hat ja auch viel
gebacken wie kommst du eigentlich zu
weit wir haben früher einfach viel rupps
gehabt im garten und das musste weg und
wenn ihr nur ein wächst ist langweilig
denn gab es auch viel obst kuchen und
dann wurde der auch eingefroren und
deshalb haben wir glaube ich gebacken
und weil ich komme ja aus dem osten das
brot war um 12 uhr wende zum bäcker
gegangen ist das gute brot war schon weg
schon da haben wir dann angefangen
selber brot zu backen und jetzt endlich
ganz faszinierend nicht so jetzt aber
wir genau jetzt einmal kurz rühren und
dann die anderen zutaten dazugeben
[Musik]
perfekt
also das ist jetzt der fertige teig
direkt mit den sauberen händen rein und
jetzt müssen war ich weiß du bist ja
auch mal größte tanja bitte koste mal
bier
und für gut befunden sehr gut dann
können wir weitermachen du bist jetzt
nicht so der abt weg von oder alles auf
ein dramolett im wagen raus ich hole
jetzt die waage raus irgendwie sein wenn
ich böse bei dieser ganzen beliebten
bäckerei in new york wo die leute
schlange stehen für diese cookies wiegt
ein kilogramm also eine praline da
höchstens acht gramm wiegen weil wenn
sie größer ist keine frage mehr ja dann
liegt ein coupé wird immer 50 liter sind
interessiert drin liegt einer bestimmt
500 gramm gefühlt ist ein loser hat
soviel nicht unter 70 zloty
du weißt sind fast zwei tafeln
schokolade ja aber hast du schon mal
eine tafel schokolade auf einmal da war
ich sehr hungrig hatte gar nichts
anderes mehr
ich war danach auch sehr unglücklich
weil ich im anschluss gleich ein stück
käse oder sogar aber ich brauche süßem
oft noch was platz
was süßes ja genau das ist ein kreislauf
es ist wirklich so und egal wie sagt man
ist ein bisschen platz mahnte luces hat
man immer
160 10 nehme ich mir noch
hast du das gewicht in den fingern
es geht
[Musik]
und dann kommen sie auch schon in den
ofen oder so näher sorry gar nicht wie
kommt erstmal in den tiefkühler ja ein
bisschen es heißt ich muss noch warten
es wurde mir gesagt das geht ganz
schnell dieser knicks
ja also im prinzip 10 15 minuten im
tiefkühler wenn ihr zu hause ein
bisschen mehr zeit habt oder auch kein
platz im gefrierschrank kommt auch dann
einfach für mindestens eine stunde in
den normalen kühlschrank das wird auch
genau schauen ob spec platzieren das
heißt wenn er nur vier drauf sind wie
groß werden die dann ausgebacken seien
nun nur minimalen die breite und ist in
frieden sie auch ein damit dies zu einem
grossen cookie werden okay also ich gehe
das man einführen dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder beziehungsweise dann
kommen sie direkt in den backofen bei
200 grad ober und unterhitze für genau
16 minuten
[Musik]
wir sind soweit in
16 minuten müssen wir jetzt aushalten
denn so lange brauchen wir jetzt im
backofen und vielleicht auch 15 uhr in
der hand haben ganz hart die sind ganz
hat das muss so damit ihr richtig schön
dick und groß bleiben genauso wie aus
new york kam mainz untere drittel
danach stehen war das zweite blech
direkt hinterher
aber so wie die aussehen werden das so
richtige hammerdinger ich glaube jetzt
nicht dass sie wahnsinnig verlaufen ich
bleiben schon so genau die sollen so
dick bleiben und dann kommt dieser
schöne moment dieses handelns machen
gute krimis ja andere frage noch mal
zurück zu unseren anderen cookies den
100 wünschen wie kann man sich denn da
schützen vor denen die unerwünschten
cookies könnt ihr praktisch manuell
löschen also wirklich nur diese paar
sekunden zeit nehmen und außerdem gibt
es ja auch von avaaz programme diesen
sogar kostenlos und dann ist man ja auch
auf der sicheren seite ich merke du
kennst dich aus das heißt in zukunft
werde ich mir auch immer ein bisschen
zeit nehmen ja dass ich nur die von mir
wünschen cookies zu last wichtig und das
kann ich alles manuell machen ganz genau
ist eigentlich super wenn du sagst es
ist wie sie denn dann glaube ich hier
dass ich hoffe ja dann läuft schon
schokolade und diese cookies werden auch
gleich so wie sie sei ja im essen oder
sieht man dann auch ein bisschen mit
klanglos ich glaube man wird nicht ganz
so elegant aus aber es ist egal
hauptsache sie schmecken
so illi sie dürfen raus wir dürfen raus
der moment der moment ist gekommen
komme ich habe hier schon alles
vorbereitet
wenn ich mein team
ich werde mit mega ich kennt gucken es
immer nur so klappt ja und da sind ja
nicht neu möge genau das sind richtige
xxl ich schieb das zweite mal direkt
hinterher das wirst du auch brauchen
und die kann doch gar nicht belegen sind
die so weich und gemacht so muss sorgt
also man kann man natürlich schon essen
aber hat dieser mensch wenn er das so
auf machst
sie sind echt glücklich ja sehr
faszinierend und vielleicht auch zu
probieren und dann darfst du bewerben
ich bin gespannt okay da ich du darfst
angeben und vorsichtig auf jeden teller
sind jetzt kann man nämlich auch gut
anheben alpha ventus und bisschen
zerfallen noch mal so richtig weil ich
genau um vielleicht noch mal zurück zu
dem internet cookies zu kommen man kann
ja auch seine privatsphäre schützen ich
werde euch da zwei links in die infobox
setzen genauso wie das rezept natürlich
es gibt aber online security and privacy
und amazon beides kostenlos es lohnt
sich da mal einen blick darauf zu werfen
und ja ich würd sagen du hast ein
bisschen auseinander gefriert dann
braucht ihr auch mal ja man muss sich ja
um cookies einfach nur kümmern und sie
sagen was ich ganz viele
kunden sagen aus in der mitte ist niki
drogen es gepackt und
[Musik]
bürgeraktion habe ich mir auch auf zwei
häuser und fachlich ausgefüllt und
irgendwann vorhin richtig gesagt also
ich würde sagen macht die cookies
unbedingt mal nach die louis cookies und
eh nicht bedanken nicht dass du hier was
hat mir richtig viel spaß gemacht mehr
auch und zum schluss bin ich sogar noch
etwas leckeres zu essen und
informationen was will man mehr so soll
sein also bis zum nächsten mal in die
wärmedämmschicht
finde ich es ganz im mund schaffst du
[Musik]